thank you
i'm sorry the house is returning in such
tragic circumstances
since we last met we have lost two
outstanding friends and colleagues sir
david amos and james brokenshire
i know honourable and right honourable
members from all parts of this house
will show my deep sadness at their loss
and will want to join me in sending girl
heartfelt condolences to their families
the circumstances of sir david's death
were despicable
and the rays of the most fundamental
issues about how members of this house
are able to perform our vital democratic
responsibilities safely and securely
in light of the ongoing police
investigation i will not say more about
the events but i give the house my
undertaking that i will do everything
within my power to ensure that these
issues are treated with urgency and with
the sense of priority that they deserve
i know that whatever political
differences that there are in the house
all members want to ensure
not just that we and our staff are able
to work safely but they were democracy
itself with local member of parliament
at the heart of our constituency is able
to function securely
on that i know the house is united